el asaltó al marido de Nancy pelosia a
primera hora del viernes avivó el temor
a la violencia política antes de las
elecciones un intruso que exigía a ver a
la jefa de la cámara baja del congreso
irrumpió en su casa en San Francisco y
atacó a su esposo con un martillo el ex
presidente Barack Obama denunció este
clima de tensión contra los políticos
cuando no solo no estamos de acuerdo con
la gente sino que empezamos a
demonizarla a hacer acusaciones
descabelladas sobre ella eso crea un
clima peligroso
Y si los funcionarios electos no hacen
más para rechazar explícitamente este
tipo de retórica más personas pueden
resultar heridas una violencia política
que temen las agencias de seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos que llamaron
a Elevar la vigilancia antes de las
elecciones de medio término ayer dijeron
en un boletín conjunto que los
extremistas podrían atacar los actos
políticos y los colegios electorales el
ataque del Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 fue un detonante de esta violencia
según este experto entrevistado por
Franz 24 estas amenazas de las que hace
señalamiento o señala por lo menos las
autoridades es precisamente ese síntoma
de que la democracia en Estados Unidos
está en peligro muy a pesar de que hay
un sector de la política y hablo
específicamente de la orilla
conservadora que que pretende tratar de
que este evento se olvide pero es una
muestra fehaciente de que la violencia
continúa de que la intimidación continúa
ahí sufrida por el esposo de Nancy
pelosi Se produce en medio de un aumento
del número de denuncias de amenazas
contra miembros del Congreso según la
policía del Capitolio de Estados Unidos
los casos relacionados con declaraciones
y amenazas preocupantes pasaron de casi
4000 en 2017 a casi 10.000 en 2021